good morning Hank it's Tuesday in a
stunning turn of events I find myself in
an airport so I've got the
seven-year-old son in every Saturday he
wakes up at 5:00 in the morning and
watches two hours of Pokemon before I
can even you know like get up and take
the iPad away from him he has all the
Pokemon encyclopedias and all these
pokemon cards I don't even know where he
gets them from I think he trades for
them on the schoolyard playground and
it's great you know I want my kid to
have passions I want him to be excited
about stuff but I know nothing about
Pokemon well aside from what Henry has
told me in a brief foray into Pokemon go
so today I thought I would explain the
world of Pokemon from the perspective of
someone who has never seen Pokemon
alright hey so we all know that the last
500 years have seen this huge decrease
in biodiversity on earth well good news
in the near future we get a big influx
of species and not just any species like
cute cuddly awesome talented species
they're called pokemons how did they
arrive on earth I have no idea was it
like an alien world Noah's Ark situation
yeah probably knock is a bunch of
pokemons are based on current earth life
forms like horsey is you know basically
a seahorse so maybe it was like a
radiation event point being there's like
hundreds maybe even thousands of new
species and you can catch them by using
these things called pokeballs like you
throw a Pokeball at a Pokemon and the
little Pokemon ends up inside the
pokeball and then you put the whole
contraption into your backpack why would
you capture all these pokemons I mean
why do people do anything ultimately
like why do people fish so you catch all
these pokemon and then you train them so
that they will be excellent in battle
wait I forgot something important
sometimes you catch like too many of one
kind of Pokemon like you've got 17
pidgeys and you don't need 17 pidgeys
and it's weighing down your backpack in
that case I believe you can transfer
your Pokemon to someone called the
professor but this seems like it's maybe
not a good idea I don't really know what
he does with transferred pokemons but I
asked Henry about it once and he said
'dad pokemons do not like going to the
professor right so your job as a pokemon
trainer is to train up your Pokemon and
make them strong so that then they can
do battle with other people's pokémon
someone I can gather it's basically like
a Roman gladiator style thing but you
know for children also they don't fight
to the death they fight until they faint
but that's not true thing anyone like
Henry explained to me dad fainting is
what Pokemon called dying and I was like
yeah no I get it so you catch Pokemon
with your pokeballs you train them up
you take them to battles and then you
fight to the fainting against other
people's
oh c'mon and as far as I can tell that's
it like it's basically just a sport it
doesn't seem like winning Pokemon
battles help save the world or make it a
more fair or just place but then again
you know neither does soccer and I like
soccer
the game has Tottenham Hotspur fans like
to put it is about glory which is to say
that you know in the scheme of things
the stakes are very well that's there's
a lot of questions I don't have the
answer to like how do Pokemon involve I
have no idea if this is identical to
fishing why not just fish and most
importantly given the most pokemons are
based either on legends like Charizard
is a dragon or on actual animals like
Rhyhorn is rhinoceros what is Pikachu he
seems to be just our collective idea of
adorable that we throw balls at and then
put inside of a tiny spherical cage in
our backpacks which is weird but I guess
it gets less weird when you considered
that that's our relationship with many
non-human animals so I think that's my
best attempt to introduce the Pokemon
universe from someone who knows nothing
about the Pokemon universe I think I
have to go get on an airplane I will see
you on Friday